There are so many modalities to help fight cancer cells and bring the body back into balance
How much or how many could I be doing along with what I'm currently doing?
Could I add hyperthermia or CBD oil?
so
Yeah, there are there are a lot of anti-cancer therapies as far as nutritional approaches
there are a lot of
You know approaches using off-label drugs. There's approaches using other physical modalities like hyperthermia
So let's talk about a few of those now part of the reason why we do the cheek swab testing and
Developing a protocol for a person is that we're trying to
Help that person
Not feel like they're they have to try everything that they hear about and then they find themselves on
27 different protocols taking 48 different vitamins four times a day. I
Think too much of a good thing can be a bad thing so just because
Bend is all might be good for one person doesn't mean everybody should be on bend is on just because
You know
Prodicell might be good for one person doesn't mean everybody shouldn't be taking protocell you can't you cannot physically do all of that and
Furthermore if you did physically do all of that it could actually make you worse because your liver has to detoxify
What your body can't use?
So if you're gonna take things and your body and you absorb them
You're gonna take extra nutrients and your body is absorbing it and your body isn't needing it to help combat your disease or your cancer or whatever you're dealing with
It still has to detoxify through your liver detox pathway, so you could be doing more harm than good
Overwhelming your liver detox pathways by trying too many things especially things that you're gonna be taking
Orally now different modalities like oh while I heard about you know hyperbaric
Oxygen is good, so I'm gonna go run out and buy a hyperbaric oxygen chamber. I heard hyperthermia is good
So I'm gonna get a hyperthermia unit. I heard cryotherapy is good. So I'm gonna get a crowd therapy tub
Saunas are good, so we're gonna get this
There's a balance of which everybody has to make that decision that is that is big reason why
Our philosophy of writing right programs that you're mainly doing at night while you're sleeping
Can't do hyperbaric oxygen while you're sleeping. You can't do hyperthermia while you're sleeping
You can't do PEMF while you're sleeping, but you can certainly do the right while you're sleeping
Now that frees you up to maybe decide to add another therapy if you have the wherewithal to do so during the day
Now when would a person choose to do a specific therapy?
It partly greatly depends on that type of cancer that that person has
So if a person has
Let's use hyperthermia as an example if a person has breast cancer is localized hyperthermia a
Good choice for care. Yes, it's an excellent choice for care for breast cancer. I won't forever cancer
Yeah, I'm a propagandic cancer. Yes, I'm up for lymphoma. No, no, I'm up for leukemia. No, not really no
localized hyperthermia because there's two different types of hyperthermia
So systemic hyperthermia is where you're trying to raise your body temperature
Systemically now
The truth is without going to a German cancer clinic and being sedated
Medically sedated with drugs and put into a hyperthermia chamber
For eight hours you're not going to really be able to raise your core temperature to it to
To the degree that it's really going to kill cancer cells
Is doing so does a hyperthermia? Yeah, let's of course. It's a hyperthermia. It's increased temperature
Is it
cancer killing
Yeah, really is it help with detoxification pathways? Yes, absolutely. So that would be a therapy to add
But it's not necessarily a cancer killing therapy
You know localized hyperthermia with the
Hyperthermia units that we use and sell that would be a a good therapy for local hyperthermia
But it would be cancer type specific like I said
Not a therapy for a blood cancer not a therapy for even a solitary solitary
lymphoma nor
For deep cancers
But it for superficial cancers press cancers things like that. It can be a great choice
And then
CBD oil you mentioned CBD oil CBD is another one
of those therapies
that
can be a
great
addition for a lot of people now some people
Do better with CBD than other people. So again, when we're talking about CBD
We have to make sure we're defying our terms correctly CBD oil
By definition has no THC in it or very little THC in it
And it's the benefits of the CBD now is that a CBD gonna be a cancer killer or any cancer?
The answer is no are there other benefits of CBD helps decrease inflammation in the brain?
It can help with systemic inflammation
You have can can can a cannabinoid receptors in
Every part of your body in every organ can it be harmful?
For the health of your tissues and the health of your organs sure
Did everybody be taking CBD? No, I mean, it's just a matter of you could say so many good things about literally every single
Nutrient on the planet, but does that mean everybody should be taking it no
The other thing when people say CBD for cancer they're really talking about THC
So THC is a totally different therapy for cancer. There has a lot of positives, but it has a lot of negatives
So there are noticed that when I put these questions in the slides, there was another question about
Rick Simpson oil or the THC therapy for cancer. So I'll say that when that comes up